from CBS right here on the rich eyes to
show my buddy Brad Nessler how are you
Brad hey my friend we call that
fellowship on those midnight that's what
I call it well your call at that I I
still call it that on Sundays when I get
together with my so-called friends to
watch NFL Thursday night I always tell
my wife I'm going to such and such you
know the local dime and she goes for
what I say fellowship seller you know
that's what we had your first ballot
fellowship bread I'll tell you that
first ballot your first ballot what is
it like I mean you've done so much
you've been there done that what is it
like settling in on the 54 LSU Alabama
on a Saturday president the United
States coming in the whole country's
watching what in the world is that like
bread for you it was really cool rich
you know I I don't think I'm preparing
any differently or anything I kind of
get ready for every game like it's one
against two or two against the reader
you know Super Bowl whatever so from
that standpoint but just you know the
electricity around the stadium the fact
that there was probably 70,000 people in
there to watch the guys warm up I don't
think they've ever seen that big a
warm-up because you had to get there
three hours early to get you know
through the turnstiles and past the
Secret Service who wanted literally a
hundred and two thousand people
including us we had to go in with the
crowd you know so that was a little bit
different um and you know just the
atmosphere was spectacular I mean it you
do a lot of those games or you think
you're gonna get a good one buta
national championship or SEC
championship or just a big game and you
get ready and then it turns out to be a
dud but when you prepare and you're
ready and you just feel it and all of a
sudden the game lives up to the billing
if it and that that was a cool part you
know you and I have been doing this long
enough to have you know good shows bad
shows great shows whatever and you know
my job is kind of to make a bad game
sound good and a good game sound great
and if you get a great game all I do is
get out of the way and you know we had a
great game so it is pretty spectacular
it sure was man now let me ask you the
question of the moment in college
football certainly in the SEC is what
has
happened to the LSU offense to make it
look so unprecedented ly good and
high-powered for LSU fans what has
happened walk me through this Brad well
you know they just changed it completely
you know Jill Brady gets a lot of credit
for it the passing game coordinator who
came over from the Saints but he did
indeed bring a whole bunch of concepts
from New Orleans you know he was an
assistant there with Sean Payton and you
know they start using client Edwards he
layer a little bit like the Jews Alvin
Kamara you know some of the receiving
groupings the stack groupings and who
they've gotten a slot how they switch
everybody up you know I was watching the
Saints in the Falcons yesterday I was
going okay this looks a little bit
familiar you know group raises and the
stolid tall is Joe Grady and you know
Joe's only I don't know 75,000 yards
behind him an NFL passing but bred you
see a lot of the same things and when
they changed it over they came over to
do son of a seminar and yet Arthur I
said he wasn't even in that group but
Steve M singers offensive coordinator
was and he said man he talked about all
this stuff that I think you know we
really should think about implementing
and then in spring ball they started to
they didn't show it much in their spring
game but they had already installed it
and then I saw Joe Brady down at the
Manning passing Academy and in late June
down in Thibodaux Louisiana when the
garden spot's of the world but really a
fun thing to go to and I was talking to
Joe and his dad and his brother with
inter and I said okay so I keep hearing
about this new offense and he said you
wait and I go really
this means Baragona recognize this is a
job Earl yeah you're not gonna recognize
it and I said I'll trust it when I see
you do it you know and then I saw him do
it
against Texas and then I saw him do it
the first time we had him second time we
hadn't been and then you know Saturday
I'm a believer now man it's there to
stay
the only problem is they got to find
another guy like Joe Byrne Medora
because their offensive coordinator said
we could have done this last year or no
he said Joe could have done this last
year but we couldn't maining the coaches
and the team weren't ready for it but
Joe was ready for it so they got to find
another guy like him and I'm sure they
will because coach he'll be recruiting
his brains out after that win and I'm
sure they'll have a guy that can come in
and do the job well the interesting
is Brad as you know one thing is I'm
watching it this was the first time I
saw it for all four quarters and was
able to just blow up in a hole in MA and
a football weekend to watch a full-on
LSU game right this offense is no chill
zero chill and by that I mean it is so
high powered in so high pace high octane
that even when they should be taking the
air out of the ball they don't and that
was one of the most aggressive 4-minute
drills I've ever seen and I know that
the quick strike that Alabama had in
response to LSU going up by two scores
right took they took away if you will
from the attention that would have been
paid to the game ceiling drive but that
was one of the most aggressive
four-minute offenses I've ever seen in
any game at any level Brad yeah he took
it what 10 minute mark maybe 75 yards I
think it was a 12-play Drive at it like
you said it took four and a half minutes
for 26 whatever and that he turns around
you know after 200 comes back and hits
duty for the touchdown and it goes on
another 75 minute drive in exactly
almost four minutes just like you said
and they never took their foot off the
gas and I thought they were starting to
just have a little bit of a dent in
their armor went to it just kept coming
back and they got back-to-back scores
and they cut it down I thought is this
where they pulled it back and you know
Gary and I were probably even question
to that on the air if we didn't do it on
here we did it to each other during a
partial and I you know and we're going
there they're gonna back it off here and
man they just kept it down just kept
going and it's amazing that the two
quarterbacks couldn't have been more
spectacular elected to to some number 22
running backs oh those guys made it a
show man I mean Nagi Harris Alabama's
not even close if she doesn't play
lights out in the second half and the
little dude for LSU man I just love the
kid because you know he wasn't a
five-star recruit and all that stuff
he's he's five eight if he's lucky if
you saw Jamie or at all interviewing him
after the game well I'm not gonna tell
you I'll tell Jamie is but I know it's
all she is so I mean he has got a huge
heart and he's going to be a healthy NFL
player - I think but those two guys put
on quite a show - not just a quarterback
yeah Edwards e Larry's from Baton Rouge
- I mean what a moment right for him to
put that on tape because again I had
mike Mayock our buddy
Mike on last Friday we had Todd McShea
on the day before I mean this is the
tape McShea said is the first tape he's
gonna put on when he starts evaluating
players for the draft this is the tape
that Mayock is probably already
reviewing for the third time since you
and Gary stepped out of the booth I mean
for him to put that blame on that tape
at that moment in that Stadium it
couldn't be any bigger for a kid from
Baton Rouge that's amazing yeah you know
and yeah and Mike knows that better than
anybody for how many years he was your
draft guru and by the way his his picks
are doing pretty good yeah thank
goodness I know I texted him a couple
times last week
yeah that's you know the coaches tell
her to do that too I mean they didn't
used to say that I don't think but both
Nick and coach George Ryan have said
that to us we tell them and and you know
we challenge them and not just the skill
position players but you know but the
offensive linemen defensive linemen hey
the first thing they're going to do is
pick the best college game that you
played in or the highest octane college
game you played in so you better play
your butt off because that's what
they're going to look at first and he's
a hundred percent right and that's how
they do it and the coaches these days
even tell the kids that so it's an
interesting concept I would have thought
you know that that didn't exist but man
it does and that's the motivating factor
for all these players Brad Nessler here
on the Rich Eisen show it's interesting
that the name Joe Brady is in the mix
because of the name Brady is what so
many people are referring to this Joe
and borough you've called Brady games I
know obviously to use a Mayock phrases
he used last Friday when I said Josh
Jacobs looked at luck Zeke to me at this
level let's not go anointing anybody
just yet but just the way that he stands
in the pocket stands tall weights and is
so patient and just cuts you up and
slices you with a quick game as well as
the ability to maybe make a quick strike
people are saying borough looks like
Brady I wonder what you think Brett yeah
I mean yeah he's got a long way to go
obviously to do something like that but
I remember I did Tom's last college game
and he wasn't even a starter full-time
in Michigan thank you you know that
better grew Hansen they tried to sneak
in there a little bit but Brady came out
in the Orange Bowl and threw three
touchdown passes to David Terrell and I
did that one and I think that might be
until last year's Super Bowl the last
night Brady was the MVP of a game
because they gave it to David trail
that's a whole side story but no I
called him jus cooled noburo his
demeanor is really really different when
you meet the kid you're not going to
quite know what to make of him and you
know it's the proverbial chip on the
shoulder thing because you didn't get
recruited at all by Nebraska and his dad
Koechner and his brothers both played
there and I asked him that two weeks ago
and he pointed at me and said good
question and like he still ticked off
about that because he would like to play
probably for Nebraska and then he goes
to Ohio State and you think he wins the
job you know and he breaks his hand and
asked him to call and he transfers and
the whole thing and now he's right where
he wants to be but I mean the
combination of his football knowledge
and he's a really really good athlete I
mean he was Allstate and basketball he
runs a lot better than most guys that
are his size that her quarterbacks he is
the toughest sob I mean every time he
gets one right in the side of the helmet
he just pops up and the whole team
rallies around him because of that had
happened in the UCF Bowl came last year
had happened in the game we did earlier
this year when he got tattooed on the
sidelines and he just popped back up and
you need to ask him about stuff like
that and he says what am I supposed to
do just fold my tent just walk to the
sideline and go put somebody else in he
said hell I'm a football player and I
said are you ever gonna learn how to
slide and he's licked me says mr. Ness I
don't slide I mean just everything about
him his football IQ is really really
strong to me when he really wants to get
into X's and O's and all that stuff home
so just the combination the combination
of how he plays with the little chip
that he plays with and the fact that
he's really talented his arm talents a
lot better than it was a couple years
ago too and he's worked hard on that
with you know the quarterback guru guys
and all that I don't know who the guy is
but he's got a lot more velocity on the
ball you can make all the throws and he
knows where to go with it you know he
knows where he's going with it
85% of the time before the snap and he's
just a smart guy and a really talented
football player so you're saying that
I'm in the Brady comparisons there's the
whole fire that stoked by the beginning
the roots the being overlooked the being
passed over that sort of business from
his past all written real the real I was
answering your question that way but you
got it my friend
gosh Brad Nessler here on the Rich Eisen
show a couple more left for you the fact
that we haven't even talked about - it
just shows you about how LSU performed
and how striking it is and maybe it's
just again it's a new thing that it's
not Alabama and Clemson and everywhere
all just waiting for it to happen so I
do want to hit you on a couple of things
on that front - looked limited to me I
wonder what he thought what you saw
leaning up and then during the game Brad
what do you think I'm leading up I
thought it practiced he looked totally
normal but that is such a regulated look
you know I mean he's never going to get
touched you know he throws the ball so
well that sometimes you get enamored
with watching just just watching him
spin it you know when you're in practice
right
you know Gary's looking at different
things than I am I'm looking at you know
where the receivers are you know duty
and and Smith and rooks and waddle and
all that kind of stuff and then I'm just
getting I get kind of mesmerized by how
well each foot ball especially deep ball
and so I'm sitting and they're going hey
he's fine he's fine he's fine well then
you get out to practice I mean I get out
to the game and I watched him warm up
and he was warming up almost in street
clothes he had sweats on but it was kind
of weird cuz he had like a golf shirt on
and sweats and he was out there and he
was trying to test trying to test his
ankles about okay Platt to jump this way
or an RPO I gotta throw it this way and
he's kind of doing these little dances
and I'm going he doesn't look like he's
enjoying this that much you know and
then when he got in a game I think Dave
Aranda did what only you got to do if
you're gonna beat him and they tried to
just get in his grill not only just
straight up the middle but on the edges
Rashad Lawrence got in his face a few
times and they made him move around they
made him rule out you know they brought
him down a couple times and he landed
funny and so from right there I don't
think he was nearly as mobile as he was
you know just right at the beginning of
the game so they defended him really
well but I mean he's what a dude man
it's real fourth touchdown pass keep him
in it till the last minute I mean it was
unbelievable I'm saying he looked
limited you said it offended him really
well and he got a four hundred yards and
four touchdowns anyway that's how
talented
oh it's crazy and his numbers are better
than last year and I don't even think he
might not even be in the top three right
now for the Heisman level so the last
one for you I mention Alabama and
Clemson and it looks like we're finally
gonna get something different we're not
just waiting around for it how do you
think this loss affects Alabama for the
college football playoffs moving forward
and eventually what do you think Brad uh
well you know their strengths the
schedule type thing is not good enough
now the I test is that they played the
number one team in the country
well I'm sure like who's gonna be number
one tomorrow on the college football
rankings if you're not there's something
wrong but you know you can say well they
played him to a five point game and they
played it right down at the end but they
did lose at home the rest of their
schedule is not very good I mean if they
crushed Auburn and the Iron Bowl maybe
what a lot of chips would have to sort
of fall for him I think you know unless
other people collapse and you know the
people don't expect that to happen I
mean you know they've done it before but
I think maybe their schedule was a
little better or maybe the other teams
weren't in that year but they're still
hope you know Nick's gonna it's going to
keep him playing and I doubt if they'll
lose again but we'll see yeah well I
mean the two of arrow was born out of a
national championship game appearance
and victory that was started in a season
which Alabama didn't even make the SEC
championship game so we've seen it
before
and maybe we'll see it again hey Brad
this was a great chat great game love it
that was awesome
fun watch thanks buddy yeah we had a lot
of fun I appreciate it man good here
yeah let's chat later on this month and
leading into the SEC championship game
and beyond Brad well chat soon
that sounds that sounds perfect and then
possibly some fellowship I'm officially
plus two I'm bringing a posse bread I'm
bringing a posse and my CBS Sports
blazer that I still have from my US Open
days take care yourself private pools
chat soon that's nestled right here on
the Rochester for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app